よろしくお願いします
今日のテーマは賛成する方法やら反対する方法とか
とにかくあの 我々持っている意見について仏教の立場を説明したいと思います
それからこの ブッダっていうのは
初めて新しい教えを教えて
その後世の中でいろいろ仏教と違った考え方がものすごいたくさんありましたのでね
その中でお釈迦様が自分の教えを教えていたんですね
ですから 人の意見に対してどう対応するのかということは
仏教では大変よく研究されているテーマなんです
というわけで これ結構難しいんです
それからものすごいたくさんところで
お釈迦様がもうもう半分以上
もう違う意見を持ってる人々と話し合っていたんですね
誰と話し合ったっても
最後にはお釈迦様の意見に納得するんです
だから このお釈迦様が使っていた方法論ですからね
これがお釈迦様自身で考えたものだから
それはやはり普通の人間にはかなり難しいと真似もできないと思います
だからもう一つ この一回の話ではね
もう触る触れることもできないということで
それだけじゃなくて 私はいろいろごちゃごちゃ余計なことをやっていて
この講演のスライドを作ることもできなかったので
半分しか作っていないんです
その上 話は難しいだけじゃなくて
まあとにかくほんのちょっと垣間見るような感じで
微妙なところだけ微妙ではなくて
ほんのもう 1 万分の 1 にも当たらないぐらいの
ほんの少々のところを説明したいと思います
タイトルは一応英訳にしちゃうとオピニオンアンドビューポイントということで
ザオピニオンザビューポイントいうわざとそれをつけたんですが
皆様 英語の場合はそういうきめ細かいところは私より大変詳しいんだから
単なるオピニオンビューポイントと書いてあってもいいし
ではなくて わざと入れておいたんです
それはまあ どういうことかというと
この意見というのはやっぱり入っちゃうんですね
文法と違って 英語の文法と違って
我々は何か意見を持っちゃうと
これは私の意見であって
ユニークな意見であって
他あなた方の意見とは違いますよということですよ
だからザオピニオンなんです
オピニオンなんですね
正しいやつは オピニオン
ザビューポイントということで
ですから副題にああいうアイデア
ああいうアイデアアンドマインズライバルズエリア
あなたの意見と私の意見というのは
まあライバルっていうのはもう敵同士かエリアというのは
まあなんて言いましたっけ
まあ同盟している仲間ですかということで
次に行きます これは皆様に報告されているタイトルですね
はい 次に行きます  意見というのは必ずしも意見になってしまいますと
それはちょっとした異なった意見になるだけの話なんですけど
我々はこのぜ入れて考えているんですね
結局は自分の意見は世の中にある無数の意見の中でもう一つだけなんですよ
葉っぱ 1 枚ぐらいのことでね
これこそ葉っぱだよとか言えないでしょうに
何か木から 1 枚の葉っぱを取って
これが葉っぱですと 葉っぱというものはこれでございます
言えないでしょうね これは世の中にある無数の葉っぱの中で
たった 1 枚だけであって
だから意見というのは
こちらに書いているようなもので
あらゆる異なっていて
たった一つだけなんです
ポイントで見てみれば
意見がある場合は他人にも違う意見があり得ることになるのです
私に意見があるんだったら
必ずしも他人にも違う意見があるんですよ
そう あの楽々に軽々ぶ
自分の意見をね まあペラペラペラペラ言えるものじゃないんですよ
意見があるともう確実に違う意見は他の人々にもある
それは見事に人間というのは無視するんですよ
The 意見ということでいるんだから
The 意見だとおかしいんですけど
The オピニオンという立場でいるんだから
唯一のユニークな意見でユニークな意見であるという
これはえらい間違いで
何かの意見なんですね
だからそれには世間は別な意見を持っている
それはすぐ無視する だからかなり問題は起きるんです
意見を述べても それを素直に簡単に認めてもらえると思う人は夢想家です
だからもう我々よく期待するんですね
自分の意見はもう素直に素直に認めてくれとかね
冗談じゃないんです そんなはずもないんです
もう誰でも子供と意見交わしちゃっても
子供だから素直に認めなさいと
ありえないんですよ それぞれ一人意見があるんです
ですから 認めてもらうという人類のこの考え方はもうあまりにも妄想ですよ
次に 人の数 ほぼ同じぐらい意見の数もあるのです
例えば何かについて何かの問題があって
あなたはどう思いますか？と人に聞くと
人の数とほぼ同じぐらい意見があるんですよ
時々一人の人が意見をいくつか持っている場合もありますから
そういうことで また一つの意見というものは
潜在的に反論 我々論に対する反論ですね
も持ち合わせているのです
これはちょっと難しいポイントで
何か意見があると その意見の中にその意見を覆す反論も入っているんです
いつでも だからこれはまあコインの裏と表のような感じで
裏と表があるんです で
それはもうどうしましょうかといって
今日は話しません これは別なテーマで
ちょっと難しいんですけど
一応それも覚えた方がいいんですよ
この仏教はその時点で相手と喋るんですよ
だからそう簡単にブッダの真似はできないんです
ブッダは人の意見は云々ではなくて
自分の意見は聞きなさいという
そういうことでもなくて
意見は持っている この自分自身を壊す反論をね
それを教えてあげるんですよ
そうすると 意見というのは自動的に崩れてしまうものですよ
そうなると ちょっと推測的に言えば
意見というのも成り立たないはず
ですから 真理の人には何の意見もないんです
今日もそこら辺は経典出してないんですけど
ブッダは何も意見持ってないんです
悟った人には何一つ意見はなし
だから我々は無知だから
もうもうあんまり面倒くさいことをしたくないんだから
意見言わない 持たないっていうこと
あんなのはごまかしでではなくて
智慧の完成者だから意見はない
智慧の完成者には意見はありませんということで
はい それでほとんど言われたと思いますが
同じことは一応わかりやすく英訳してみたんです
読んでみてください これいらないですね
一応 あなたのご意見といえば
もうサンファクトリービューポイント
自分の意見の基本的な構成
ハップドゥーユーフレームアウトビューポイント
何か意見は我々はどうやって
まあなんて言いますか
フレームっていうのは気付くこと
作り立てることなんですね
どうやって我々は頭の中で意見を作っているのかという
この盾やり方について
はい  1番目は本当のことを言っているということで
アイムテリングザトゥルース
意見を述べる人は 自分が本当のことを言っていると思っているんですね
だから自分の意見というものは
自分にとっては真実なのです
よく覚えておいてください
たった世の中にある無数の葉っぱの中で
たった 1枚の葉っぱなんですけど
自分にとってはそれが真実なんですよ
自分の意見が 嘘言ってるわけじゃないんですよ
嘘は嘘は意見にならない
嘘を言っている人もいますよ
でもそれは意見にならない
例えばもうもう何て言いますか
人をちょっといじめたくてからかいたくて
まずいものがあります
あるんだけど これ結構美味しいんですよと言う
これすごい美味しいんだと
その人の意見のように見えるんですけど
それは意見じゃありません
ただ嘘を言っているだけ
人をからかいたくて 本人の意見はこれはまずいという意見なんです
それで聞いた人が嘘に騙されて食べてみたらものすごくまずかって
もう嫌になったと そしたらもうその人はまあまあからかわれた
からかったんだから喜んでいるかも
だから嘘を言う場合は意見ではございません
事実をわざとねじ曲げていることを本人は知っている
アイデアがひらめいたら驚いてワクワクして他人に言いたくてたまらない
これまだ大きな問題なんですね
ちょっと何かアイデアが頭に浮かんだら
もうワクワクして驚いちゃって
言いたくて言いたくて
たまらんですよ だからこそ世の中というのはものすごくうるさいんですね
喋るは喋るは喋るは もう
事実確認に暇がないというより無視する
自分の意見に対して事実確認
この意見は本当によろしいかないかとかね
ちょっと確認する そんなことできん
もうもうもう興奮しているんだ
アイデアが浮かんだだけで
それでも言っているんです
だから事実確認する気持ちは全くない
暇がなかったというわけじゃなくて
無視するんです 結局は
そんなもんで はい 次に行きます
意見にも弱点があるんです
自分の意見だからこそ
それが可愛い 大事にしたい
これが弱点なんです 自分の意見だから可愛いんですよ
自分考えたことだから
だから大事にしたいんですね
これが誰かに壊されて
攻撃されて 非難されて
批判されて欲しくないんです
そうなると結構まあ問題を起こしちゃうんですね
だから他人が弱点を示すと
弁護弁解しなくてはならないという
とんでもない罠にはまってしまっちゃうんです
いい加減なんか意見がひらめいた途端もう言ってやるという
もう黙っていないんですね
当然もう興奮しちゃって
瞬時に言って言っちゃう
言った時点で相手が別にもっと知ってるかもしれません
そうすると批判したり
違うでしょうと言ったりしちゃうと
本人がもうまだ研究もしていないのに
もう弁護しなくちゃいけない
もう可愛いんだから 自分の意見は
弁解しなくちゃいけないということになるんですね
まあ馬鹿みたいに弁解する
しなくたっていいんだけどね
ああ そうかと それで終わっちゃいますけど
普通だったらそうしないんだよね
弁解しようとすると これでものすごいもうややこしい複雑なもう世界がそれから現れちゃうんですね
あっちこっち足が引っ張られるんですよ
弁解しようとすると それに弁解しよう
そう言ったってもこうではないか
ああ言ったってもこうではないかと言っている間で
どんどんもう何が何になるかというと
徐々に自分の意見は自分自身になってしまうんですよ
もっとひどいことになるんです
ただの意見なのに これ
自分自身 相手の批判は自分の批判だと思っちゃうんです
私を侮辱しているんだと思っちゃうんです
私を批判しているんだと
私の意見を批判しているのではないんです
だから批判する側も同じ人間だから
お互いにそうやって罵り合い
侮辱することになってしまうんです
これは自我との同一化なんですね
で これはもう随分軽く言ってますけど
仏教ではもう大変大きな
もう徹底的に人間考えなくちゃいけない問題として扱っているものなんです
自我っていうのはほとんど意見なんです
私がいるんだ 私に魂があるんだ
そこまで発展しているんですよ
単なる意見なんですけど
意見に対する批判は自分に対する攻撃だと思う
だから結果として自分を攻撃したんだと
それで神様を攻撃したんだと言って人を殺されたりもするでしょうね
意見を言う権利さえもなくなっちゃうんだ
あんまりにも自我と同一化させちゃって
はい それからこの感情の侵入ということが起きるんですね
まあまあ とっくに起きてますけど
それもあります 意見に対して
意見は単なるアイデアではなく
感情で丸にしたものになる
意見っていうのは単なるアイデアですけど
我々は瞬時にそれは自分の感情と結構混ぜるんですよ
混ぜて別なものにするんですね
感情と混ぜちゃうと もう訂正が効かなくなっちゃうんです
意見っていうのはもしかすると間違ってるかも
でも訂正できなくなっちゃう
感情に入っちゃう 感情が入っちゃう
例えばよく私にあった話でね
日本の仏教を批判すると
もう何もできないんだ
協力も何もできませんよと
別に批判したってもね
もう利害も害もないはずですけど
意見と 照らし合わせないと
総合しないと説明できるものでもないでしょう
それから他の宗教は放っておきなさいと
なんで批判するんでしょうかと
まあ放っておきますけど
私が言っていることを理解するならば
その能力もないんだから
みんな知っていることを私は言うだけなんですよ
だから 自分が仏教の考え方っていうのは
できるだけ控えて控えて減らして減らしてって理解できないんだから
まあ世の中にある誰でも正しいと見事に信じているものから始まるんです
そうするとかなり嫌な気持ちになるんですね
訂正する気持ちには全くならない
意見に感情が入っちゃうんです
そうしちゃうと もうどうにもならなくなっちゃう
訂正が効かなくなっちゃうんです
で 意見が感情づけになったら
強引に言う 相手に押し付ける
自分の意見はこれ 感情づけにしちゃうと
とにかくもう強引に押し付ける
いかがでしょうかというか
立場がないんです あんた方はどう思いますかと
これについてとか それもないんですね
これがいいですよ やりなさい
認めなさい これがいいでしょう
本人の勝手でしょうね
私にとってもいいかどうか
私が判断しなくちゃあかんでしょうね
すごい強引に押し付ける
それは強引な人々 また弱気になって他人に言えなくなる
これはまあ ごく一般的な人々ね
強引な人々っていうのはそうたくさんいるわけじゃないですけど
で 感情が入っちゃうんだから
これ批判したら困りますよとかね
で いうことで弱気になるんですね
別に意見尽くされたってのは
批判されたってどうってことないんですよ
なのに これ自分自身だから
自分自身を攻撃すると思ってるんだから
自分自身を批判されていると思っているんだだから弱気になるんです
弱気になったところで
自分の意見があっても言えないんです
だから意見があるにも関わらず言えない人々はみんなもう弱いんですよ
なぜ弱くなったのかというと
この感情が入っているんだからなんです
気持ち的に弱くなった人は
曖昧な言葉の山に隠して自分の意見を言う
どうしても言わなくちゃいけない時は
もういろんな言葉 喋って喋って喋って喋って
自分の意見を言うんです
すごい言葉多すぎ 私の講義みたいな
もう結構 もうもうもう時間無視で喋る
テレビなんかではね いろいろ討論会とかなんかある時はね
司会者がすごい厳しくカットするでしょ
割り込んで割り込んでカットしなかったらどこまで喋るかわからないんですね
秒単位で時間が決まっているんだから
そこでカットするのはすごいプロ的でありがたいことなんですけど
結局その人も感情的で自分ばっかり喋る
だから最悪なんですよ
テレビ討論会っていうのは
司会者の話 例えば 30分の討論会だったら
司会者の話は 15 分ぐらいしかいかなくちゃいけないんです
それでコマーシャルも5分ぐらい入れて
もうせっかく来たプロたちの話はもう 10 分ですね
それにも見栄張って呼ぶんですよ
もう一人じゃなくて もう 8人とか
偉い大物 それで何やってるんですかと
ただの束縛やってるだけで
みんなこの人々はそれぞれの世界なプロで
自分たちの意見をちゃんと持っていて
もう説得させようという感じで来ているし
それで立てようと思ったらもう喋り出すんだから
司会者がやっぱり割り込まなくちゃいけないし
この司会者が自分の意見ばっかり喋りやがっちゃうんだから役に立ちません
それは大体アメリカとかね
かなり長持ちする人々というのは
かなりすごい鋭いがすごいですよ
ラディカルとかね で ビシビシ喋りますけど
すぐすぐに喋り終わっちゃうし
とにかく相手から言いたいことは取り出しちゃうんです
ガチャガチャ言わせない
自分でピックアップして取り出しちゃうんです
その時間の中で その人々っていうのはすごい珍しくて
そういう人々は結構長生きしますよ
テレビ世界では そこで私たちの場合はもうとにかく感情がある
弱い しかし 意見を言わなくちゃいけないしね
それでまあそうですね
そういえば まあそれについてですね
まあまあ考えたところで
まあ私はですね まあ皆様
そういう言葉で喋って何喋ってるんですかね
結局は 何の意味もない話をずっと言う
結局何言ったのかと 私は結構皆様に感じるようにさせることはありますよ
結局は質問された時は
また言ってやれ 何を聞きたいんですか？あれが触れない
喋るは喋るは喋る 説明するわ
序論もあるし もうその背景もあるし
そんなどうでもいらんでしょうに
質問すればいいのに 知らないところだったら
相手がそこは逆にいろいろもう質問するでしょう
それでピリオドがないし
だからもうもうもういいだろうでしょうと思ったところで
私はまあその話を切って
何言いたいんでしょうかね
では 質問は何ですか？いつもそうな質問といっても
ほとんどの場合そうなるんです
それがこの気持ちが弱くなっちゃって
この感情が入り込んじゃって
意見は言えなくなっている
でも言えなくちゃいけない
それで言葉の山に なんとか隠しておくんです
見つかるのは大変です
それからよくある話で
この かっこいいと思ってるでしょ
相手の気持ちを案じるって方
そんな自分の意見言ったって相手にも気持ちあるでしょとかね
よくかっこいいと思ってますけどね
全然かっこ悪いんです
他の気持ちを重視して意見を控える
よく見ると これ真っ赤な嘘です
これ嘘ですよ 人なんか他人の気持ちは全然重視してないんですよ
だって感情はあんまりも高ぶっちゃうと言いたい放題のことを言ってるんじゃないんですかね
人の気持ちはどうでもいいでしょう
みんな人の気持ちは全くもも気にしないで
自分の意見ばっか言いたい放題言ってる割にはよく言うんですね
やっぱり人の気持ちも重視しなくちゃいけないんだとかね
口先だけ実際はやってない
自分の意見が正しいのに
なぜ言わないで遠慮するんですかね
もし自分に意見があると
当然自分の意見は正しいんですよ
自分にとっては これ前のポイントなんです
自分の頭に浮かんだ意見は
自分にとってはすごい正しい
ぴったし だったらなんで言わないの？失礼でしょう
正しいことを知っているくせに言わないということは
それはすごい失礼な態度なんですよ
遠慮する必要はないんです
それで弱いんですね 感情が入り込んでいるんだから
感情が入っているんだから
言いたくはないんですね
言いたくないことをこんなごまかし言葉で言うんです
これ言ったらね 相手の気持ちもあるんだからとか
なんとかとかね 言っちゃえばいいのに
弱くない時は言うんでしょうし
感情の大体入ると弱くなるんですけど
感情ばっかし頂点に行っちゃうと
もうもう病気だからね
その時は発作を起こしてるんだから
怒りとか欲とかね 嫉妬
憎しみ そういうものがぎゅっと上がっちゃうと
堂々と意見を言うんです
病気になっても だから感情はそこまでもう赤線まで行ってない場合はもう弱き
その時はまあなんとかかっこつけるんですね
他人の気持ちも重んじて
重視してとかね 実は自分の意見が感情づけになったので気が弱いのです
理由はそれなんですね
感情の衝突だけは誰でも避けたいんですよ
別に意見の衝突は 本当に正しく意見を衝突されている経験があるのあれば
怖いことも何ともないんですよ
別に何のこともなく終わっちゃいますよ
でも感情の衝突はこれはものすごい嫌なんですよ
向こうも怒って こちらも怒って怒って
あるいは向こうも欲張って
こちらも欲張っちゃって
こちらはこちらで儲かりたいし
向こうは向こうで儲かりたくて
時にも感情ばっかり一気に出しちゃうと
もう話にならもうものすごい嫌なんですね
だから人間というのは感情の衝突は嫌がるんですよ
だから子供 それすっごいうまい武器にしていますよ
親はすごい時 こういうこと大きいんだから
子供っていうのは何のことなくへっちゃらで感情をむき出しにするものです
よくあるのは攻撃的で怒ることなんですね
ものすごい平気で怒るわよ
小さい場合は怒り 怒り
怒りっていうのは泣くことなんです
ものすごい強烈になる
で 親はもうこのまあこの感情
これ嫌なんですね そうすると相手の考え方は聞いてあげるんですよ
だから たとえ子供であろうとの感情がむき出しに出して衝突しようとすると
これがもう何とかしてでも避け避けたいということになる
そういうよくあることで
だからこの意見があると
まあ言わないとかね 人の気持ちも考えましょうとか
なんとかなんとか 訳も分からないことを言っちゃうんです
よく我々の社会にある
このすごいかっこいい言葉っていうのは
調べてみると何の意味もない危険な言葉なんですよ
一つはこれなんですね
相手の気持ちもよく重視しなさいということ
実際はないんです そんなことは
はい 衣装に体を合わせる人もいます
これだけでもおかしいとわかるでしょうね
体に衣装を合わせるんで
衣装に体を合わせるっていうことっていうのは
もうあまりにもあべこべでしょ
それやってるんです 怒り
憎しみ 欲 高慢 嫉妬などの感情で心が最初から汚染された場合の意見はおかしいんです
これは異常に体を合わせることなんですよ
最初から何か感情がある
怒りか憎しみか 例えば自分が憎しんでいる人がいる
憎しんでいる人が何か新しいものを発明する
これになんとかしてケチをつけようと悪口ばっかり言うんですよ
それも意見ですよ そんなものを発見発明したっても実用性はないんだ
自然破壊するだけだ 社会は受けるわけはありませんか
なんとか言うんです 意見すべて感情に合わせてるんですよ
事実に合わせてるわけじゃないんです
だから 例えば嫌やと思っていることについては
いつでもなぜ嫌なのかという理由しか探せません
日本のことわざもありますね
まあ覚えているのは坊主が嫌けりゃ袈裟まで何でしたっけ？坊主が憎けりゃ袈裟まで憎いと
坊主は憎いのはいいんだけど
なんで袈裟まで そういうすごい立派なことわざなんですよ
それで可愛い場合も何かあるでしょ
あばたもえくぼと 欲が出てくるとそんなもんになるんですね
それをその人の意見なんですよ
変な意見ですよ これ 衣装に体を合わせるんですよ
感情に意見を合わせる
だから正しい意見を作りたければ
気をつけてください 自分が感情で考えているのかと
感情でいえば ほとんどこの今
こう書いてる場合で 欲と怒りが一番大きいし
憎しみも嫉妬もある機能するし
怯えも機能するときあるし
例えば初めからもう怯えている
その場合はいろんな意見を言う
まあ例えば戦争の話で
初めからもう戦争はもう嫌ではなくて
怯えているんですね 戦闘に行きたくない
もう怖い 結局自分が死にたくないだけで
そうするとたちまち平和主義者になるんです
でも なんで戦わなくちゃいけないんでしょうかとか
なんとかとか言って平和主義を謳うんです
それ 平和主義という意見が別にデータきちんと見て作ったものじゃなくて
本人が行きたくないんだからなんです
だから特に怖さっていうのはよくありますね
例えば会社にしたっても
課長 部長 社長のことをちょっと怖いとやばいと思っちゃうと
もう自分の意見をすぐ合わせるんですね
相手の気分に それが自分の意見として堂々と言う
で そのように感情に意見を合わせる
そういうのは少ないことなんですよ
それっていうのは立派な意見ではありませんね
これは衣装に体を合わせることですよ
結局は で そのポイント
それで終わります それで最初から色眼鏡をかけているので
意見には必ずバイアスが入る
そこで感情っていうのはバイアスなんですよ
怒りという色眼鏡 憎しみという色眼鏡
例えば 日本人は決して北朝鮮に対して普遍的な公平な意見は持てないと思いますよ
中国に対しても普遍的な公平
意見は持たないと思いますよ
アメリカ人に対しても同じなんです
それぞれバイアスがあるんです
心の中に アメリカに対するバイアス
中国に対するバイアス
北朝鮮に対するバイアス
韓国に対するバイアス
えらい違うでしょ 最近になってきたら
なんだこれ 韓国に対するこのバイアスは
韓国のものなら何でも最高ってなったでしょうに
今まで悪口言ったくせに
言っていたくせに もう韓国料理は流行っているわ
どんなところでも まあ普通のあの牛丼とか何とか売っているところでも
今 韓国の名前の何か料理
一つや二つは入っているんです
で マクドナルドやらそういうところはまだ研究していないんです
私は 何か入っていると思いますよ
だからそれ意見のごとく見えますけどね
やっぱりハンバーグの中で韓国バージョンも韓国風も何かあった方がいいんじゃないかなとかね
すごい新しい意見と思ってとんでもないんです
あれは感情に合わせた意見なんです
だから そんな難しいことを置いておいて
皆様 日本の方々は 例えば中国に対する意見と韓国に対する意見といえば見方すごく違うでしょう
アメリカに対してどう考えているのかというと
また見方がさらっと変わっちゃうんですよ
それで我々色眼鏡を持っているんです
色眼鏡たくさん持ってます
全部まとめてバイアスということなんですね
この我々は このバイアスで物事を見て意見作るんですよ
これがまずいんですよ
衣装に体を合わせるんじゃないんですよ
あべこべですけど やってるんです
例えば中国人は嫌いだという前にね
中国人はこういうことをやったんだ
ああいうこともやったんだからね
本当に だから嫌いになったと
結果として言うならば順番でしょ
アメリカ人はこういうこともやってくれた
こういうこともやってくれた
だから絶対もう信頼しようと言うならば
もう順番なんですけど
逆なんですね それで主義
主観 自分の生き方 自分のものの見方
持論などはこのバイアス入ってから現れるものなんです
全ておかしいと私は言った
言いたいんですよ 主義なんかはいい加減にしなさいと
これは衣装に合わせた体なんです
成り立たない あべこべなんです
もともと衣装に体を合わせないんですよ
初めから 体に衣装合わせるの普通です
だからこの主義なんかは初めからもうおかしくて成り立たない
主観というのも同じことなんですよ
それで これは私の生き方ですよと堂々と言ったっても
ほとんど論理性ないんですよ
なんでそういう生き方になったのかと
この段取り その過程を持ってないんです
聞いて いや 私は昔からそういうことですよ
それは話にならないんですけどね
それから役に立たない
正しくない このバイアスで作る意見と
感情に基づいて噂で作る意見というのは役に立たない
正しくもない だから 例えばマスコミで流しているあの情報なんかは気をつけた方がいいんですよ
このインビジブルラインスという英語の言葉がありますよ
何でしたか 日本語になると
それは このラインの間を読むと
文章の  行間を  読む 行間を読むでしょうかね
これしないと 自分でわざわざ研究しなくても
その人々は研究して バイアスでね
データ出してるんだから
その中で行間を読んでみると
本当にあったことを見えてくるんです
それほど頭は良くないんですよ
だからバレない 簡単に
だから私は大体人の意見を聞いてから
その意見の反対の側面はよく発見する
相手に聞こうとはしないんです
一方的で十分です  裁判の例で言えば
もう裁判で この被告人に対してもう証言をする
誰かがもう検察側から
で 被告人の方が いや 違いますよ
別な証人立たなくちゃいけないでしょうね
本当に聞いていると あの話で十分です
こういうわけで こういうわけで
この人は犯罪だよという
あの意見の中で入ってます
データが 時々弁護士は反対尋問して
それを 引っ張り出すでしょ
例えば私はその人を人を殺すのを見ましたと
ではどれぐらい距離ありましたかと
とりあえず映画でやった話でね
これぐらいだったと それで何のことなく
その時間 普段あなたは何やってますか？とか
関係ないことを聞いて
それであなたは眼鏡かけてますかと
で 本人はどういうふうに見える？私は家を朝は眼鏡かけません
出かける時は眼鏡かけますよ
で あなたは窓から見たでしょ
眼鏡かけなかったでしょ
で 終わり 何のことなくバレちゃいます
はっきり見ていないんだと
ただ その人は嫌で言ってるんではないかと言って
何かまた情報を探すんですよ
あんたはその人とこれ
この間なんかちょっとやりあったんではないんでしょうか？とかね
そういうふうに裁判で弁護士たちは反対尋問するときは
この証人の言ったことの中にも逆な考え方
逆なことも入っていると
だからこの行間を読むということで一応わかるんですよ
そこまでどうでもいいんですけど
一応マスコミなんかはね
韓国の韓国のニュース流すは
アフリカのニュース流すは
アメリカのニュース流すわとかね
情報を流すわとかね 全部バイアス入ってます
だからそのまんまじゃないんです
事実は 決して そういうことだから役に立たないんですよ
偏見的な意見なんかはね
例えば北朝鮮に対する流す情報によっては
決して北朝鮮と韓国は仲良くなるという見込みはなくなっちゃうでしょ
いくらなんでも国一つも国二つ対立するのは良くないでしょ
結局は 対立したりぶつかり合ったりして
やがて戦争の状態にもなるっていう風に進んではいけないでしょう
戦争っていうのはとんでもないもう破壊行為で損ばっかりするんであって
誰も勝てないし 戦争する場合は
だから人のことを愛するんだったらね
心配するんだったら もうちょっと気をつけた方がいいというところもありますけどね
でも感情で嫌いというたった単純な感情で
ニュースはバイアスになるんです
はい それからそういうことで浄化法
今までの説明で 我々はもう意見の問題点いっぱい
弱点いっぱいあって まあ意見の構成
組み方 型で言ったっても
それはあんまり説明できません
意見というのはパッとひらめくもんですよ
どう思いますか？と言った途端
もう思っているんですよ
何かを だから意見の もうたちまち瞬間にもうひらめくもんで
そちらの構成っていうのは何ともないんです
その中である問題 その意見はどういうものかとまずずっと説明してきて
その問題はどう解決するのかと
1番目はひらめいた意見を考え直す
意見はパッとひらめくでしょ
それからそれはもうちょっと考え直した方がね
よろしいんですよ 正しいかないかは確かめる
これで正しいかないかどうかね
興奮して曖昧 瞬時瞬時に発表しない
あの NASA の発表のように
アメリカの科学者あれやこれやとかね
いい加減でも曖昧で興奮しあがっちゃって
科学者らしくないし もう発表するは発表するばっかり
ふちゃふちゃですよ 行間を読むと正しくないとわかりますけどね
誰も行間が読めませんだからね
そのまま鵜呑みにする
だから何か意見が浮かんだだけで興奮してね
瞬時に発表するんじゃなくて
ペラペラ喋るんじゃなくて
きちんと考え直して確かめてみて
これでいいのかどうかね
で 自分の努力の範囲ですけどね
それで自分が考えたことを言うものなんですよ
意見は自分自身ではなく
客観的なまたは主観的な単なるアイデアだとしっかりと自己確認をする
これ 自我統一化っていうのはものすごい危険なことなんです
これが仏教から言えば何よりも危険です
自我統一化 意見と最後になってくると少々説明します
どれほど危険かと その時はもう聞く能力もなくなってるかもしれませんだけど
とても危険なんですよ
だから ただのそんなアイデア浮かんだよと
ただのアイデアだけや
ただの意見だけだというふうに思った方が自己確認するんです
これは私ではありませんと
ただ浮かんだアイデアですと
それはたとえ主観的であろうと客観的だと別に関係ないんですよ
まあ客観的なことっていうのは
結構物事を見て出ているアイデアでしょ
それでもただのアイデアだと
主観的ってのは自分の主観的な主観だからね
まあそれでもただのアイデアだと思っちゃえば
客観的な主観的な場合でも問題は起こりません
だからこの私ではありませんと自己確認することで
これは意見であって 私ではありませんと
例えば主観的で言えば
私はあの人のことは大嫌いやと
憎いだという感情ですけどね
感情に絡んだ意見ですよ
人に言う場合は意見だからね
それは主観的な意見なんですね
これは主観的な意見で
私ではありませんと思っちゃうのはそれほど問題になりません
次は感情が割り込むと意見は邪見になると覚える
意見に感情が入り込んじゃうと
もう邪見なんです もうダメです
役に立ちません アイデアが浮かんで
同時にこれ好きになっていくと
もう邪見になっているんです
何かアイデアが浮かんで
それからそれに続いて怒りが割り込むと
もう邪見になっているんです
だからこの感情が割り込むことはあります
侵入することはありますから
侵入したら邪見になっているんだと
もう人を人に言えるものではありませんということにしなくちゃいけないんです
感情が先立つ先立つ意見なんかは役に立たない偏見だとする
もう感情が先にあるんだったらね
こんなのは役に立たないんだと
怒りが先にあって それから考える憎しみが先にあって
それから考えるんだったら
もういい加減やめた方がいい
役に立ちません だから
これは人間だからわからないで
時々怒りが先にあるんですよ
怒りが先にあるんだったら
それを気づいて もう意見なんかは言いませんと
意見ないんだと もう頭の中でゴチャゴチャあるんだけど
全部正しくないんだと
もう自分には正しい意見判断できない状態である
怒っているんだからと
そうしなくちゃいけないんです
その時は必ずしも偏見なんですね
それからもう一つ 浄化方法っていうのは
この批判を聞く 自分の意見を言ったところで相手方の批判があります
それよく聞くんですよ
聞いて驚いた方がいいんです
気づかなかったところがある場合は
驚く準備をしておく この驚くっていうのは
このポジティブイメージの驚きなんですね
本当にびっくりして驚いた時
私は全然それに気づかなかったと
これ楽しみにしなきゃいけないんですよ
自分が何か意見を 論文を発表したところで
あっちこっちでいろいろ言われたところで
いろんなことをボロが見えてきて
自分が参考しなかったところがわかってきて
ああ よかったよかった
驚いちゃったねとかね
全然気づかなかったと
という風にものすごく舞い上がって喜んだ方が立派なんです
嫌になるんじゃなくて
これバレたらまずいとかね
あの人は例えば研究でレポート発表なんかの場合はね
あの人が何か言っちゃうとやばいな
怖いなとかね ではなくて
どんどん意見を言う人に意見を聞いて驚けば
驚きましたよと 私はそこまで考えてなかったんだよとかね
立派な人っていうのはそういう人々なんですよ
私は大学で学生 学部で勉強した時は
もうものすごい難解な仲間だったんです
授業中で それからレポートを出す時とかね
もう全く先生たちが言ったこととは違って
ものすごい違うところまで進んで
調べて調べて書いたり
出したり 言ったりもする
というと 先生たちというのは本当に素直に喜ぶんですよ
すごく笑って ああ 私はそこまで考えてなかったよとかね
私はこういうこういうところしか読んでないんだよとかね
堂々と言うんですね そうすると学生の身分の私は
何やこの先生と思わないんですよ
なんかすごい尊敬しちゃうんですよ
いい先生だとだけじゃなくて
自分にももっと自信を持って胸を張って調べる勇気が出てくる
先生が驚いてくれるんだから
それが楽しくて 今度は驚かせてやるぞと
何か先生知らないことを発見してやるぞということをやっちゃうんです
それで私も成長しましたし
先生たちも素晴らしく後輩を指導する
立派な先輩の方々として役目を果たしたことにもなる
人々に得するだけ だからまあ
私たちみんなそういう性格でいれば
自分が言った意見に対して人が何か批判したら
これよく聞いて 自分気づいた気づかなかったことが言ってくれたら
これ驚いちゃえば楽しくなっちゃって
すると相手の気分がよろしいし
自分も成長する だから批判を聞いて驚く準備を常にしておかなくちゃいけないんです
これは浄化方法です まあ大体ここら辺でなんとかはい
次に行ってみましょうか
それで大事なところですから
このファインチューニングオピニオンは同じことを英訳なんです
それで皆様方は浄化っていうのはファインチューニングではないだろうとかね
思うかもしれませんだけど
一応英語と日本語っていうのは直訳はしないんです
文化違うんだからね で
辞書を引いちゃうとピュリファイとかね
おかしいんですよ ピュリフィケーションのオピニオンとか言っちゃうとね
もうなんだこれっていう感じになる
だからそれでまあファインチューニング
ドゥノットゲットエキサイトジャストビコーズユーハブアイディア
これ間違ってユーハブアイディアなんです
レッツユアアイディアゲットマチュアビフォーイットイズエクスプレッスト
言う前に自分の意見が熟するまで待ちなさいと
英語は日本語にしちゃうと
逆にまた翻訳しちゃうと
いきなり言うんじゃないんだよと
アイディアがかなりもう熟して食べごろになるまで待った方がいいんです
えーと ユーアンドユアオピニオンアトゥセパレートシングスノットアイデンティカル
あなたとあなたの意見というのは全く別々だよと
同一なものではありませんと
メイクイットシュアダットユアオピニオンイズナッシングバットアイディア
あなたの意見というのは単なるアイデアであるということをはっきりしなさいと
ウェザーイットイズサブジェクティブ
オブジェクティブ 主観であろうとも
客観であろうとも 単なるアイデアであると確認してくださいということ
アンドオピニオンサップスイーツセルフトゥビーアバッドベリーバッドワンアットザモーメントアンドエモーションペネトレーションイントゥイット
例えばオピニオン 意見に感情が入り込んだ瞬間で
サップスというのは置き換えて繰り返してしまうんですね
バッドオピニオン とんでもない悪い意見にもう変身するんですよ
アンドオピニオンレッドバイエモーションイズバイアスアンドユースレス
エモーション感情に先に出る
感情に導かれた意見というのはバイアスであって
ユースレス 役に立たない
エンジョイクリシサムアンドディスカバートゥポインツユーハブミストゥコンシダー
エンジョイクリシサムね
批判を喜んでください
批判を喜んで 自分がミスった
気づかなかったポイントを発見してくださいということで
それで浄化方法なんです
はい ここまでの結論 よくまとまった意見は感情で進んでいないということ
意見はまとまった まあまとめないで立派な意見だったら
これ感情で進んでいないんですよ
感情は全く関係ない 入ってないんです
これ あれ遅いんですよ
アグッドオピニオンハスナッシングトゥドゥウィズパーソナルエモーションズ
ということで これここまでの結論で
その次にちょっと行ってみますけど